moi je travaille sur le phénomène de
l'islamisation et donc toutes les
preuves de cette islamisation toutes les
la visibilisation de l'islam sous
différentes formes ça peut être les
jeunes femmes par exemple comme vous qui
veulent que y ait le voile islamique
dans les tribunaux ça peut être
l'offensive islamique à l'école avec des
jeunes filles qui veulent rentrer dans
les dans les lycées avec leur voile
islamiques ça peut être les horaires de
piscine ça peut être le halal dans les
cantines ou alors le fait qu'il n'est
plus de porc dans les cantines il y a
plein de si vous voulez de de symptômes
qui montrent une islamisation du pays
moi je m'intéresse assez symptômes et
donc lorsque j'envoie et bien je les
partage et quand vous les partager c'est
dans quel intérêt pour montrer justement
ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est-à-dire une islamisation c'est une
islamisation de la France il y a des
symptômes de cette islamisation et donc
je le montre tout à fait mais vous les
montrer parce que vous recevez des
candidatures spontanées
justement j'allais dire en toute
honnêteté le monsieur donc le
journaliste qui vous a envoyé cette
photo vous vérifiez pas à chaque fois
qui est-ce qui vous envoie la photo tant
que vous avez à manger vous le partagez
ça que vous faites parce que ça
m'étonnerait que tous les journalistes
toutes les photos que vous avez publié
que ce soit à chaque fois des
journalistes qui vous les envoyer
et auxquels j'ai confiance ça peut être
des militants de reconquête par exemple
ça peut être voilà des gens ou alors je
vérifie qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tweeté ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois si
je vois que c'est des gens qui sont pas
hostiles qui sont plutôt dans mes idées
il y a aucune raison qui me piège je
recoupe aussi les arcs les lieux la date
quels sont vos idées là-dessus parce que
moi j'ai vu voilà des tweets vous avez
mis vous avez mis un tweet par exemple
en plus de dépenser de l'argent public
pour des projets de monétaire à
l'étranger nouvelle Aquitaine banalise
et promeux le voile islamique dans une
campagne publicitaire je vais vous
montrer les différents tweets que vous
avez fait comportement et regarde
pervers on dit stop témoin de
harcèlement sexiste trois conseils pour
agir rapprochez-vous de la personne
harcelée ou agressée adressez-vous à la
victime comme si vous la connaissiez
prévenez un agent TCL ça vous aviez
reposé voilà pourquoi le terme banalisé
comme si c'était quelque chose illégal
c'est pas illégal le voile je ne dis pas
que c'est illé je dis que c'est un
symptôme de l'islamisation de mon pays
selon vous de notre pays et selon vous
il y a pas et c'est quoi l'islamisation
et vous vous êtes le docteur c'est ça
parce que les symptômes
de musulmans dans mon pays a été
multiplié par 1000 en 70 dollars que le
nombre de mosquées a été multiplié par
1000 en 70 ans et alors j'ai pas envie
de devenir le Pakistanais de devenir
l'Arabie Saoudite j'ai pas envie que mon
pays devienne le Libanais mais vous avez
conscience parce que vous définissez
comme un lanceur d'alerte je me permets
de vous rappeler que le lanceur d'alerte
il dénonce des crimes ou des délits
on sort le code pénal mais vous savez
moi je vais vous répondre sur
l'argumentation vous alertez de quoi
vous êtes ralentir de haine vous savez
ce que vous êtes pénal et les lois de la
République elles n'ont pas été conçues à
une époque où il y avait des musulmans
dans notre pays
le droit il n'est pas adapté à la
présence de millions de musulmans et
déniciens
il va devoir s'adapter la loi va devoir
se corriger pas du tout pour pouvoir
répondre à la tentative de conquête de
l'islam de l'espace public notamment
vous êtes dangereux je le savais en
regardant vos publications mais là la
vérité dangereuse et là voilà votre
vérité votre vérité c'est que vous
détestez les musulmans il faut le dire
que vous êtes obsédé depuis des années
dans les musulmans je voulais montrer
leur culture et quand il n'essaye pas
d'islamiser que vous êtes un idéologue
d'extrême droite vous avez été de
génération idéologique c'est juste une
réelle
non c'est votre réel fantasmer de la
haine
générale c'est ce que tu voulais dire
c'est qu'en fait son groupe a été
dissout pour provocation à la haine et
il se prétendent leur défendre pour
avoir simplement fait une frontière
symbolique justement
qui a crié au nom de allahu akbar et qui
a qui tuer pardon qui a blessé très
gravement plusieurs personnes à la gare
du Nord vous savez ces gens-là c'est des
gens qui passent par la frontière et
donc symboliquement quel rapport avec
les musulmans qui sont en France
depuis 1970 le nombre de mosquées en
France a été multiplié par 24 et le
problème c'est la laïcité c'est ça qui
est beau je crois pas il y avait
j'ai dit depuis 70 ans pas depuis 1970 à
mon avis
en 1950 il y avait que la Grande Mosquée
de Paris la grande mosquée de la réunion
ce que ça vous dérange dans votre
quotidien mais ce qui me dérange c'est
que mon pays est en train de venir le
Pakistan et je n'ai pas du tout là
en quoi est en train de regarder le
public regardez nous on a un prix
d'avoir un public vraiment qui
représente je trouve la France
splendeur et c'est vrai que regarder
qu'est-ce qui vous dérange avec vous et
personne n'a vu quelqu'un qui est dans
la rue aussi quand vous voyez des gens
qui sont issus de l’immigration
qui sont ici de l'immigration comme
ça qui font des réussites
exceptionnelles en France qui est emploi
des des des des des centaines de
personnes qui sait très bien moi voilà
pourriez prendre il y a comme avocat ou
pas est-ce que je pourrais le prendre
comme fille
un avocat doit prendre tous les clients
un avocat normalement doit pouvoir
défendre tout le monde la défense tout
le monde oui mais on choisit ses clients
quand même
l'avocat du libyen qui a fournir des
gens
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout je pense que sur les
problématiques moi je suis attaqué par
les islamistes qui essaie de me faire
taire donc je ne prendrais pas une
islamiste pour me défendre
à mon avocat par contre pour diffamation
et c'est pour un jour public que je suis
islamiste
par exemple qui veut la mort des
homosexuels vous savez sur votre compte
Twitter j'ai regardé un petit peu les
live
parmi tant d'autres typiquement et du
coup quand il parle moi il y a pas de
problème à la fin de l'émission sur mon
compte twitter il y a pas de souci alors
on va regarder ça tout de suite
certaines sourates par exemple la
sourate 40 verset 60 qui finit par ceux
qui se refusent à m'adorer entreront
bientôt en enfer vous avez liké la
sourate 2 verset 20086 qui finit par
tuer notre maître accord de nous donc la
victoire sur les infidèles vous avez
liké la sourate 23 verset 6 qui explique
qu'on a le droit de faire l'amour à ses
esclaves voilà et puis vous avez liké
aussi le prédicateur ou tayamine qui
réclame la peine de mort pour les
homosexuels donc Madame voilà
si vous likez Ben Laden par exemple les
gens vont comprendre peut-être que vous
avez une approche
de répondre et puis une communication
il m'a démasqué alors je vais lui
répondre ça va très très simple écoutez
bien déjà un on est là pour parler de
votre Twitter à vous pas d'humain et le
mien complètement je sais que vous me
traquez depuis quelques mois je l'ai vu
vous avez si vous avez regardé quelque
chose non non mais attendez je vais
aller jusqu'au bout moi vous me faites
pas peur moi je prends le devant
personne non mais vous allez m'écouter
non mais vous allez moi je vous ai
laissé parler moi je trouve devant
personne je suis droit dans mes bottes
je suis très transparente et je suis
très bien ce que je fais je suis très
intègre alors écoutez-moi bien non
seulement j'ai liké les versets qui les
qui qui dit ils sortent du Coran mais en
plus je l'ai dit puisque c'est dans mon
livre c'est dans le Coran et j'assume
complètement maintenant si on prend des
versets qui sont pris de leur contexte
et qui sont pris ah là il y avait rien
de mal je parle attendez je parle pas
encore du tweet euh de l'autre là je
parle de des versets du Coran
précisément vous ouvrez le Coran il y a
tout écrit dessus vous doutez bien que
si je suis musulmane et que si je porte
un voile je lis ce livre maintenant
a-t-on la science pour prendre des
versets comme ça et de liker comme ça et
vous êtes bien malin parce que pendant
la pub quand vous m'avez montré les les
versets là vous avez cité la fin de
versa vous avez pas cité ensemble mais
ça on y passera c'est pas grave ensuite
on va revenir au savon donc je dis aux
enfants parce qu'il a très mal prononcé
mais c'est cher retailing donc c'est un
symbole c'est bien monsieur visiblement
je connaissais comme je connais votre
nom alors vous êtes quelqu'un d'affaires
c'est un savant d'Arabie Saoudite si il
me semble il y a quelqu'un mais pas du
tout j'ai jamais mis les pieds mais
qu'est-ce que vous me raconter alors là
ils sont toute la panoplie je vous dis
un truc il y a eu des rigolo avant que
vous il y a eu des Messia il y a eu des
où il y a eu des amours vous vous êtes
le dernier ouais vous vous êtes le
dernier d'une longue liste
je vais m'expliquer
la citation que j'ai aimé les gens sont
bien je voulais juste savoir si j'y
connais rien si ce monsieur que vous
avez reliké et effectivement
spirituel qui n'avait absolument rien à
voir si vous voulez dire des stations
dites monsieur
au courant de ces positions du tout j'ai
même pas lui c'est des kill la personne
qui l'a dit la citation m'a plu je l'ai
aimé ah parce que toute situation qu'on
a aimé donc on peut pas dire du Céline
Dion
homophobe je crois mais sinon si vous me
dites à côté de ça je sais pas qu'il
avait des tweets homophobes
ça va cet homme n'a pas Twitter je crois
il me semble en fait
franchement
c'est ça après une citation qui a rien à
voir avec le sujet de l'homosexualité
une citation que j'ai trouvé jeudi j'ai
même pas regardé qu'il a dit j'ai aimé
d'accord et quand bien même j'avais vu
je ne suis pas au courant de déposition
de ce monsieur là et moi je vais vous
dire un truc parce que là ça fait déjà
la plusieurs fois dès qu'on voit une
musulmane avec un voile en fait vous
vous êtes pas content vous tremblez
parce que vous avez dit une
communication excellente je parle mieux
que vous vous avez rien à mon prochain
vous abonnez-vous vous avez voulu me
faire une Manelle vous avez voulu
regarder mes tweets escala il met un
truc sur la Syrie nana il y a rien sur
moi monsieur il madame a aimé des
citations c'est tout ce que j'ai fait et
vous tout ce que vous relayez et vous ce
que vous vous êtes à l'ensemble
vraiment heureusement que le ridicule ne
tue pas mais la haine que vous véhiculez
elle elle tue et vous vous êtes un homme
parce que moi écoutez moi bien moi je
suis moi je suis étudiante en droit moi
je fais de malade personne j'ai pas du
mal
par contre vraiment vous préparez vous
donnez à pleurer et c'est vraiment
vraiment triste parce que vous avez vu
franchement mais tout le monde vous
faites vous êtes burlesque tout le monde
ici vous serez ridicule vous êtes mais
bien sûr que non je ne veux pas l'avoir
en homosexuel mais et on en a à se poser
cette question là première mon humanité
parce que j'ai encore sur la tête et bah
interrogez-vous dans votre coin arrête
de parler sur Twitter on dira photomaton
le gars il est diffuser photos toute la
journée il sait même pas ce qu'il dit
vous êtes là vous retoutez des trucs
merci beaucoup
et écoutez-moi bien j'ai juste un petit
truc j'ai 18 un petit truc là les
musulmans qui se taisent et qui ont peur
c'est fini moi je suis droit dans mes
badges j'ai vraiment vous ne me faites
pas peur ah oui c'est fini regardez-moi
bien ce que tu sors trembler c'est
terminé maintenant vous avez une femme
j'en ai dans la tête je suis une femme
je porte un voile je suis comme en
français